servus skates und herzlich willkommen
zum ersten block seit langer langer zeit
ich sitze gerade hier noch in unserem
aufnahme und produktions keller magath
noch das thumbnail für das video am 19
also am gestrigen tag führen dass ihr
seht gleich wird gepackt und dann in
einer dreiviertelstunde geht es auch
schon los dann fährt der bus zum bahnhof
und ich fahre nach köln trepte max und
morgen gehen wir etwas richtig cooles
so sachen gepackt was erstaunlich ist
wir sind noch in der zeit
damit hat der tatsache dass ich ungefähr
schlechteste packer bin den es überhaupt
geht warum er so lange aber wer noch
zehn bis der bus fährt also
nicht
dahinten wollen wir
praktischerweise ist da drüben direkten
vapiano sehr gut ausgewählt
wir sagen jetzt gern mal kurz rein und
schoss max macht und natürlich schon
ganz darauf ein zimmer an
natürlich darf bei einer übernachtung im
hotel jugend uhr nicht fehlen
ich habe gerade vier oder fünf ansässige
brauchen diesen einsatz zu sagen und
casey deswegen zeige ich mal kurz mal
zimmer hier gibt es nichts zu tun aber
viel mit menschen in den kleines doch
über dadurch fahrzeug drauf geschmissen
das geht nur noch kurzen spot hier
drittel wo es ist kein großes spektakel
aus gefällt mir nicht ganz gut übrigens
was ich noch sagen wollte
dieses ganze setting erinnert mich voll
an berlin in berlin will ich auch im
motto bonn damals mit luca und felix
also links lot wenn ihr seht dann lasst
mich zwischen als würdet ihr mehr ein
fakt über mich leute wahrscheinlich habe
ich jetzt gerade einfach mein zimmer
karte nach fünf minuten verloren das
gibt's nicht diesem raum ist noch nicht
ausgepackt meine tasche liegt da und
meine zimmer card ist jetzt schon weg
und das beste ist das passiert mir
jedesmal jedem hotel ich will dir immer
sofort die zehnerkarte alter ich gerade
hoch zu max gehen aber jetzt muss ich
erst mal die karte suchen
er habe ich gesagt dass sie vielleicht
hier in diesem schlitz steckt da wo ich
dir auch gerade rein gesteckt habe ja
williams max
die
hey lady jemand der schon mit berlin
deswegen darf man nicht werden jetzt
müsst ihr die kontrolle gewisses oder
john roger olsson am tag leiter ihr spaß
macht so gut oder er konnte person aus
der drähte dahinten wir halt mal drauf
junge das einfach so krass kommt ihr die
welt alle junge gibt diese leute ich
glaube verlassen
so
der nämlich leute lustigerweise waren
wir genau die papiere gezeigt habe essen
während der video days und wir sind im
taxi angefahren da vorne lang und ich
weiß auch dass da vorne so eine art
spielt war zwar genau da unten
und da kann glaube ich trainieren ich
denke einfach herunter guckt ob ihr
vertrauen zu gewinnen kann
ich treffe mich mit luca wir gehen auch
immer was essen das heißt du kannst was
irgendwo was trotzdem dann besprechen
wir gern auch kein immer schön ein paar
youtube projekte
mich geht der tag in köln schon zu ende
morgen drehen wird eine geheime sache
mit max 4 grad eben noch einen kleinen
mitgestalten trocken den peter wie du
lernst so lernt man lange congo after
einfach spaziergang machen unterlagen
auch sehr viele leute das war's vom
heutigen blog wir sehen uns dann wieder
welche vietnam